[Music]  from Kendall dinner supporting her  rumored boyfriend ASAP rocky to Kourtney  Kardashian packing on the PDA with her  new man it's couples night in can enjoy  a hard time fun day Kendall had her  midriff on display in a black crop top  and leggings to attend the 28 year old  rappers show in kanne at the Gotham  nightclub Wednesday night a source  previously told et the pair won't be  making a public announcement of their  relationship anytime soon but quote  Kendall is happy I like to keep my  private life pretty private meanwhile  things seem to be heating up for court  case love life she was spotted  hand-in-hand with Eunice Benjamin after  ASAP show showing off her mane and legs  in a sexy pink sequined mini dress  [Music]